so this is the scene uh
song make it work veronica's jangle is
uh
trying to make the body 3000 work and uh
anika noni rose his daughter strange
daughter
is uh coming back to pick up her
daughter
wondering if she could make uh her
relationship work with her father
says he wants to make it work again let
the long road back
to love again it was really wonderful
scene to shoot i think because there was
so much
uncertainty with jessica my character's
name she didn't know what she was going
into she knew how much she loved her
father at some point how close they were
and she knew that she had
sent her daughter into that space with
the hope
that they would be able to have a
relationship and maybe that would help
to mend what they
lost but she's also going with a lot of
pain and a lot of
loss so it's a very very raw scene for
her she's also put on her
baddest gear show up after
after so many years looking raggedy she
came fierce with a traveling hat
i love my costumes i think they're so
stunning
and i think that um
michael wilkinson is genius the fact
that he mixed
victorian style with african fabric
was so great and so lovely
and also when i first came in my
costumes actually were different colors
and we were talking about them and i was
like michael i don't
i don't think she should stay in dark
colors i think
that she should not stay in mourning the
whole time i think these colors should
speak
um and he came back with these other
colors like this
rich rich fuchsia and this gold and this
brown that maybe wouldn't even thought
went together and it was so beautiful
without being loud without speaking
outside of the character
so i love that he did that but he also
managed to make everybody's costume
look like it spoke specifically to them
to their bodies to their movement
to their um space within the world and
there's forest uh doing his thing when
we meet him he's just finally started to
try to believe again
he's lost so much hope every little hour
that i spent
is gonna be worth it in the end
if i just get it i'll just get it to
work again when jessica actually shows
up
his whole world stops for a second
doesn't want to make the wrong step or
take too quick a step to make her get
scared away
uh it's like it's a possible dream that
he doesn't know what's going to happen
just tries to like learn the arm and
gets the chance to do what he's been
practicing doing or getting to say all
along which was
i'm sorry yeah well uh forrest was
channeling his
inner sam cook that's what he was doing
up in here because
it got good to him you know he's a is an
actor's actor so he's a method actor so
he said the the meaning of the scene and
the depth of scene and the character's
nuance and the backstory
and then i saw the head bob and he said
oh all that stuff went out the window
that was like that's when he's like
grabbing himself and trying to believe
again and fight again and he's working
and he's trying to
mold everything right get everything
good and and uh
he's accepted that we can maybe happen
you know maybe he can rekindle his life
you know but when jessica shows up it's
a different thing because
he never would have expected he could
see her almost you know
it was a moment in the film and nika
knows it's
11 o'clock hour song and it was a song
where
uh in the theater it's 11 o'clock people
been sitting in the theater for a long
time
they're about to fall asleep you need
something to wake him up
and so we needed this and um and we let
anika out the gate and
she did her thing you know it was such a
it was such a gift this song because i
think that jessica is such a genteel
person
that it would be i thought
when i heard the song that you would
have wanted it to fit more
what her character was visually what her
character
looked like and we recorded it once i
recorded it once um
in that way um while still doing it full
throttle and then you were like you know
what if we put some stank on it and i
was like and
thank you you know because i i often
don't get to sing in this register
um and i love the fact that
we got to open her up and throw her guts
out
on the screen this woman is scared at
this moment you know she's nervous
she's hurt she's sad she's excited as
well i think a little bit a tiny bit
i'm more like anxious and she has a lot
of feelings that she has to get out
and i like to see women be able to show
all aspects of who they are as they move
through so you get
you know you get places where she's
still that hurt
child and then you get places where that
she's this grown woman
who is also feeling you know i better
not walk into my own hurt child
um and when i walk in the door
god i hope i can hug my father again
um all of that in that amazing song
the first day that i came onto the set
and david you brought me
and phil and felicia dangles and things
and we were mind blown
i was like is this the hobbit
it was so stunning and so beautifully
put together
and i think that everybody paid such
specific attention to every little thing
we also didn't talk about hair sharon
martin was
head of hair and i know that lynn also
was very
um hands-on because you all had very
clear ideas about what you wanted the
hair and the costume and the makeup and
all to be
but something was created that allowed
us to have
first and foremost natural hair which
thank god
i've been in movies as my own black
woman self with
a full head of white woman hair and
it was you know it's incongruous when
that happens
um but in this time period you know
people forget there were no relaxers
you didn't you weren't doing all of
those things so it would have been
natural hair that you turned into
phenomenal things and all of the
hairstyles were based on
off of african styles that were found
um and utilized within this victorian
style world
and i really think that that's one of
the beautiful things about what you all
did with this piece is that you melded
the styles
so cleanly um that maybe if someone
doesn't mention it
maybe it's not noticed except i will say
the people online are like look at that
natural hair
you know people are excited about it
because
it um it celebrates who we are
without releasing it from the hair to
the costume
to the music to the movement everything
is a celebration
of who we are without being a commentary
and it was important when we talked
about veronica's jangle
um he traveled all around the world i
want to make him
feel international and uh um
to get his you know his his all the
inventions and things
and so we looked at we're in the 1800s
and usually what we see in a narrative
you know in the 1800s
it is a whip against our back in every
movie if you see black people 1800 it's
a whip against our back
and i want to introduce a different
aesthetic a different visual as we were
inventors and thinkers and scientists
and alchemists
and and around the world and so if we're
showing black people in the 1800s we
have to say well they either
defected from america or
or just a generation moved from afr
removed from africa so we wanted to pay
homage to
the patterns from africa um so we mix in
the victorian style
uh with a pattern from africa michael
wilkinson went to ghana
to get uh fabric and mix it in and we
created this thing called afro-victorian
i was going through looking at things
looking at papers looking at the toys
looking at the inventions
um trying to understand my place in all
this
and uh i think it was full of
it was really truly like the way you
said full of wonder
you guys did something really amazing um
they were all kids again everybody
became a big kid again
you know that that was probably the
spirit of the set is that you know
we weren't making a film for kids we had
all become
kids in many ways again
and it just you know added to the magic
yeah
it all led to this moment which is the
most tender moment in the film
um for me um and it's the one i can't
watch
and not catch a tear uh because after
this
song and this this this aggressive song
and rhythmic song you cut to okay
now what we should leave now
for you to make it by morning
jessica i'm sorry he kind of abandoned
his daughter
he he wasn't there for her and
in a way he got so isolated that he he
was treating her
i mean not purposely like uh he wanted
to get away from him right away
he didn't want her around he didn't want
anybody to see his shame with family and
not being able to do what he said he was
going to do
and i think when when he realizes that
he pushed her away and it's the last
thing in the world he wants because he
loves her so much and they're so close
then he's he's been saying what can i do
to fix this i've been trying he's
writing all these letters and stuff and
it's
hopefully he gets to come to this point
where you can just say you could just
tell her
she's sorry she could just know that he
loves her and
it was just a mistake i was too weak i
wasn't strong enough
given everything that happened i wasn't
sure that you wanted to hear from
me so i didn't send these letters
i wanted you to have the world reach
into the heavens
there was a line earlier the narrator
said that um
um many times he sat to write talking
about uh
his daughter jessica he says but he
couldn't
come up with the words i suppose i'm
sorry hadn't quite been invented yet
and it was just a great choice that you
did when she was walking out the door
and you just reached out like it just
came out of you you're like all these
years it's been
you know but underneath you you know i'm
sorry
yes but please don't go before i get to
say i'm sorry you know
please let me see i'm sorry can i tell
you that i love you and i know you might
not believe me but i
i do you know i think
that other little little tiny
sink song in there you're saying maybe i
can hold you tight
tell your life it's full of love i want
to be there for her
like i should have been there for you i
think that that's all
honestly that's all you wanted to say
and that's all she wanted to hear
and i've talked about this a lot but
there's something about even when you're
an adult
when you go back home you turn into the
child you were when you left
the last time you walked out of the door
the first time you walked out to be on
your own
and so i've raised a child i'm not
finished
i've lived a full life but what i want
is for my daddy
to love me and hug me and let that be
okay because he was my hero
and that is where we come together
i i think one of the hardest things
parents have uh
to is to the power of i'm sorry because
no
matter how strange the child is from
their parent if they
they could fix everything which is two
words they can fix everything
all right everything if two words would
fix everything
i'm sorry and and the way you all in
that scene you know i was a blubbering
hot mess in the scene that's why i
picked this
because i think if you have a tear in
a duct in your body it's gonna drop here
and when you all did in the scene and
the tenderness and the
unspoken relationship
here it's just masterful i think it's
masterful yeah i'm just i'm getting
goosebumps just
just thinking about it and it was a
naked vulnerable moment and both of you
allowed us to
to capture that you know you know when
we decided we're trying to figure out
how we can stay connected and
she's like maybe i will say goodbye to
her to
to journey and she's like well she's
probably sleeping maybe we could stay
tonight
we could stay tonight maybe we could
stay for christmas it's just
just so tentative but they're so
desperately trying to
hold each other connect each other you
know they really want to embrace
is that wow everybody 3 000. it's really
him
what's left of i was hoping to
put it back together for journey she's
taken quite a liking to him
if we start now maybe
maybe we could put it together by
morning
these are people who i think used to
communicate
we communicated between with the magic
of
what we knew you were a scientist and i
was a scientist and
you it was taken from you and you
released it
and in a different way was also taken
from me and i released it
but we were people who were used to
being able to communicate in our own
language and i think a lot of that
probably wasn't
in silence where every now and then
you'd say something but you didn't have
to
and i i love the fact that that's
what was able to happen again and that
the magic that you let go of you're
getting back
the magic that i let go of i'm
recognizing
or was taken i'm recognizing and
reclaiming
and rebirthing through my child got it
check that hey